hello, how are you, I am at
the cayman field facilities where
today the león club had its first
training session very early before
the final of the lix cap against
sanders they wished the linesman tomorrow at the
stadium it is worth mentioning that león comes from
beating pumas  2-0 with goals from
Santiago Colombatto and Santiago Armenio
the 11th starter in the last game was
Cota
Meneses Rodríguez
Fernández Barreiro Ramírez Mena Rodríguez Tesillo Colombatto and Dávila we will see if this is going to
be the starting eleven against they wanted
sanders tomorrow he reported to go it is not
Nothing in Spanish
Natalia Lanzelotti